they're predicting that 45 of women will
be single and childless by 2030. so much
so that big banks are investing in like
cat food wine like things that go with
like single women wow yeah okay so I
feel like my voice does matter so now
navigate through this space so it's like
it's like again it's such a small
percentage of men that you're like
looking for now I know yeah
um how do you want to navigate that like
moving forward
um do you even want a date like right
now because you you um
so I know some people when their kids
are young like just don't want to date
how do you like feel about that
um I think it has more to do with
where I'm at
um emotionally and
it's not even like a jaded thing right
it's more of
I know my value
I can talk to I can have one
conversation with a guy now and I know
exactly what he's about
so most of the guys that have presented
themselves in front of me just want to
[ __ ] me
I'm not interested in that and I'm going
to keep my I'm going to keep an open
mind and I'm going to keep an open heart
but I know by how a man approaches me
how he speaks to me I know that there's
that that he wants more with me it is
just I know so that's where I'm like I'm
not going on dates right now I'm not
talking I don't have somebody that we
talk every few days every day
I have no masculine energy besides like
my family our family friend Jerry
um I have no masculine energy
in my in my in my sphere in my bubble I
don't because I think
I focused on men and just dick in
general for a very long time
and now I'm I'm just gonna get to the
business
um I understand that the window the
percentage it's it's it's changed a lot
from when I was 22. so all I can do is
kind of equip myself financially take
advantage of the opportunities I have
now to set myself up because I can't
rely on
a man and coming someone coming to save
me I can only save myself now so that's
why dating is not a focal point but I'm
not like turning guys away that that
actually want to get to know me like the
real me not just want to [ __ ] me and say
all the right things and [ __ ] me because
I can see through that too so I just use
discernment now where I'm like
no guys even really try to talk to me
like or I should say um no guys that
it's like I don't know no no of course
of course guys no no no I'm saying of
course those guys in my damn like random
people yeah but guys that I would be
interested in they there's really nobody
trying to talk to me like that and
that's okay that's fine would you date a
guy that's a normal nine okay would you
date a guy
makes 40 000 per year and he's not hot
he's just like all right
average guy
average guy he has a little a little
weird he's like skinny you know little
beer belly
no no
I take care of myself I'm in the gym
four to five times a week
um at whatever his salary is to me I
feel like I still want to be attracted
to the person that I'm with and forty
five thousand dollars well you could be
in the gym a gym gym membership's twenty
dollars a month so if I'm again I had a
kid a year and a half ago I look damn
good so it's like I would want someone
who takes care of their body so the the
beer bellies were not where he lost me
it wasn't even really the money thing
it's like the attractive is like dead in
the face but checked
40 000 a year
no I don't like what I'm looking at and
then like especially too as they get
older like I like the salt and pepper
like they get sexier like I want to date
someone that I'm not attracted to would
you date someone like 20 30 years older
30 years older
he's salt and pepper and fine
probably he's okay
because it's just like even when girls
say they're like breaking down their
standard it's like do we really
I think I I think I'm like you know
percent of men most women find
unattractive what
not not just okay unattractive okay 80
you probably find 80 of men unattractive
so even if like just and that's why I
say like even if you find a guy
attractive like you just think he's fine
that means other girls think he's fine
that's top 20 of men
and again and it kind of just puts us in
the same predicament where it's like
through our 20s like this this is what
the guys are complaining about it's like
okay through our 20s we're gonna sleep
around with the the rappers the
entertainers and maybe like you know
most girls I I would say I know the
manosphere says differently don't don't
have access to the guys you would access
to right but it could be like the town
rapper the town like what whatever it
was right yeah and those guys will never
commit and if they do commit they'll
probably cheat and then we come at 30
and say take me now maybe with a kid
from someone yeah and it's like the guy
comes in and feels like he's like
settled for because the guys he really
wanted were in your 20s
and it's kind of like what you're saying
is kind of reiterating this because you
just said now like you don't have the
guys you want in your DMs anymore
correct but this is how it's meant to be
because a lot of people have
villainized me and I've played into that
actually I'm gonna say people have
villainized me and I have villainized
myself because it's like well instead of
fighting against it and you know uh I
don't know trying to convince people I'm
actually a good-hearted person it's
easier just be the villain
um so I do feel like the villain element
is a lot of I would say more so what
guys fear right because they're thinking
she's gonna hurt me she's gonna write
about me she's gonna this
um so to be honest I wasn't meant to be
with any of those guys in my 20s like
there it wasn't a match like there's
nobody then that I'm like I wish they
would take me seriously now no like they
I like them the same reason they like me
I'm trophy [ __ ] to them and they're
basically trophy dick to me we both got
what we wanted I mean essentially we
want to have sex that worked I mean yeah
you have sex and you maybe want to start
being in a relationship but you don't I
didn't [ __ ] know them like that
there's a lot of guys I didn't really
know on that level to even it makes
sense so it's not even like you were
saying um
I'm trying to think the sentence you
said before we started this conversation
though I was this this topic
um so so it's not even that I'm like oh
I wish I had those options it's just
more so like that [ __ ] was shallow
anyways everything was shallow about it
like you didn't really want to get to
know me from me yeah but anyway that's
like the woman's point of view you know
what I mean like but they didn't want to
get if they wanted to get to know me
from me
it's been a little different no but I'm
saying like from the men's point of view
it's gonna be and this is just you know
again what what the guys are saying yeah
but it's like yeah you made all those
like you let all those guys hit for free
and now I gotta do all this well it's
not even I don't even look at it as well
you did it for free because I'm not a
prostitute like and I'm not a glorified
escort right and that's that might not
be how you look at it but this is that's
crazy this is this is just like this is
how men see it it's like it's like okay
blessing
producer
you have you you took your girl on dates
right yeah how would you feel how would
you feel if you took her on let's say
five dates before you hit I don't know
what y'all did I'm not and then you
found out that your Bob down the street
without taking her own [ __ ]
like it hurts it's like another man's
ego no that's fine it's not even it's
just like no I mean but that's where
it's where I have to come in and say
okay like I'm not saying your ego
shouldn't be hurt I'm saying you're not
somebody that
is even like we're not on each other's
radar so the man that I want can't can't
care about who the [ __ ] I went on it who
I did what with and that's a small
percentage so that's why it's like him
saying that he's allowed to feel that
way I mean that's fine like you're not
on my right I think the point is like
all men think like this I I'm not gonna
generalize all I just can't like we can
say majority but I'm not gonna
generalize and say all because it's like
what my biggest issue is is like once
you hit a certain age you're no good
okay so so women we get we hit 30 and
we're basically useless to society
to most men that's how they're gonna
feel that are also has to go on
the wrong way it's again we it's the men
that we want that feel that way because
those men have options
80 of men women find unattractive
those men will date 30 year olds they'll
date single mothers they'll do all of it
it's it's the 20 of men that we want
when they say Okay single mom or no
single mom I'm gonna pick no single mom
because it's just less headache no if if
I could pick a 22 year old or 32 year
old I'm gonna pick a 22 year old that's
fine it's not to say nobody gets through
but just like on a balance of
probabilities no and that's fine I just
think and I think I think the men
sometimes get frustrated with us because
they feel like we've been sold this
fairy tale that's just not real and
these men are not real
like to that and that's that's where
they come in and say like women are
delusional for like wanting these things
I mean and from their perspective that's
valid that I don't have to
like if that's how however whatever
percentage men you want to say that's
how they feel you're saying all I'm
saying I'm not I'm not gonna categorize
the things
I'll give you five percent okay five
percent okay well then I'm only
concerned about the five like I I have
no like I'm not I'm not Jehovah's
Witness I'm not here to convert you guys
shouldn't think this way about me you
should see me as it don't see my value I
don't I don't know I'm not saying like
there's nothing you can do yeah you're
where you're at you can't undo them and
you slept with yeah
what it is you you you have you have a
child so you can't undo any of that
there's no point in harping about it and
I think that's the point you generally
try to make yeah is that I accept the
repercussions of my decisions good bad
or indifferent but my only point is I'm
just trying to like let you know this is
how the men see it as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation how helps and it helps
make what we do possible